oh hi uh so have a question for you guys
do you guys remember planking
you do that's good did you guys remember
owling
yeah how could you forget that one well
guess what
there's a new kid on the block and his
name
is mailboxing
go figure they want to take some guesses
on what that actually is you basically
go up do a mailbox stick your head in it
shoot a 15 second clip and post it on
the internet and you just mailboxed who
does these types of things who comes up
with these ideas who decides to take a
word add an img to a film a video and
post it on the internet
what's that
he said i've done that before
mailboxing
what's next knifing
knifing
yeah let's make that one a trend
you